hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm Donald we are going to watch a long
video today yeah because it's most of
the comments these days the do maternal
official gameplay reveal I want to give
a page for the day shout out though
really quick to a man named Jay that's
all we have for him here I mean we
probably know his whole name based off
the patron pledge but he's not revealing
that so I don't want to reveal that this
guy is an awesome product designer from
Alabama moved to San Francisco but right
now I think as we're talking he is on a
trip in Amsterdam oh yeah he is going
there for a design conference he says
he's a little nervous about it but dude
you have nothing to be worried about you
are a charming friendly and I'm assuming
good-looking guy meaning they'll do
great with the prostitutes over there
red-light district and also the marriage
of Ghana I'm trying to you know wiggle
the words around so we don't get these
yellow dollar pills sign that stuff over
there get some LCDs gonna be so good
you'll get to do it in a public cafe
this is gonna be the easiest deal or
whatever you're going there for business
you've ever done yeah I'm so jealous of
you Jay don't worry well we'll make it
out there someday and maybe we can meet
up with Jay while we're there no we
won't
this channel is dead reaction channels
are dead all them I'll never get it not
once a month do we get any good video I
don't know how we're still here you know
making a living off of youtube having
subscribers the channels dead nobody
cares about what we do
look down
[Music]
[Applause]
so heavy they look like heavy metal guys
yes they do they wrote this song it says
other thing to say thank you to be
reminded of politeness thank you all for
joining us I have to start by saying
that we have an unbelievable time so
much fun with you every year at QuakeCon
but there is just nothing like these
years for me to show you what a teenage
developing on it is the best thing ever
and we wouldn't want to debut doom
eternal anywhere but right here to you
at QuakeCon consider any conference it
might have champion actually how many of
you were here in 2014 when we shared our
first look at the last doom special
thanks to you for joining us again and
for your continued support also thanks
to everyone watching on the streams it's
great to have you here with us this year
so welcome let's get to it you ready to
rip and tear
[Applause]
favorite creative director to take a
fatty rib Slayer you want to feel
Unleashed right nothing is holding you
back I have a pure unfiltered action FPS
experience and to do that we started
with a very simple goal make him the
strongest and most powerful hero we've
ever created predator sex with Master
Chief woo I've done the conspirators
with an explosive bolt all of that wire
the Slayers own super shotgun there's a
little thing on the end there we call it
the meat hook and you're gonna love what
you can do with it's totally I wish
these guns were real skull gun everybody
has a different favorite gun because
each is unique and powerful tool for
killing the biggest and baddest demons
you've ever seen that's right because
you know a hero is only as strong as the
enemies he defeats so if you want to
feel like a badass good you got to wreak
some amazing bad guys along the way bfj
dude eternal has some incredible enemies
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
an elemental new bad guys destroyed you
check out this Wow do you know that's
pretty cool the story behind that you
know the coolest enemies deserves the
coolest death so we're spending more
time and energy than ever before making
sure it feels absolutely amazing and the
time you shoot punch kick slash or
otherwise rip and tear one of the demons
actually weave act we've created like a
whole system for this down internally we
call it destructible demon alright
these guys really know what their
audience really know I bet they do have
that much fun designing these fill me up
pretty well
yeah Master Chief I just pissed off a
lot of people oh actually to keep before
halo 3 before
[Music]
I want to play this so bad this is the
kind of game look out cool wash she's
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome the nightmare I've told this
nice guy is like the new Godzilla
grapple and shoot at the same time dude
[Music]
yeah crowds loving it yeah
Your Honor Earthlings can plug this wall
messed up Bert summers think so yeah
Kjell of that stuff do I look like the
Hellraiser II this like kinky
yeah bone formations like oh man if I
were to be one character to be that guy
it looks like you eats a lot yeah I want
a soul that's cool haha taste your own
medicine psycho boom yeah there's that
guitar
do repent repent Chester does die at the
gap
dude
nothing can destroy you they said they
wanted me go powerful projection this
gotta happen take time to watch this
killed boom whoa
why are we playing them I love that like
this grapple and shoot at the same time
yeah nice damn
[Music]
[Music]
this this game looks makes going to hell
look like a lot of fun yes if hell was
guaranteed to be like this yeah you get
plugged in with a gun and just told to
decimate
[Music]
whoa this guy looks like a challenge I
know actually you know whoever's playing
as the main character as no challenge
here this is like a walk in the park
he's making this look way too easy
oh yeah you climb [ __ ] well yeah we
they're gonna surprise this with other
things Wow whip that [ __ ] and
half gory details man
[Music]
Wow
that thing's a challenge for this guy
[Music]
oh yeah I got ripped apart I want to see
you get ripped apart oh my god
I'm at is pretty scary were actually
playing yeah dude that is this game like
VR this would be like a perfect VR game
and I think they are doing a PR PR do
love them like guttural scream oh dude
this guy's great it's just fine Morty I
can scope it in it yeah hey well he
needs extra life he was getting killed
out there he was doing terrible I
wondered I'll never be as good as this
guy never know man never know
[Music]
demonic deduction yeah he's going inside
of a colonoscopy right now yeah yeah
enter the I wouldn't be surprised if
you'd had to enter like a giant rectum
in a new hell hell is bloody the earth
[Music]
this is when I start to dislike the
liner notes where you can read like
where he's done tongue stuff like that
whoa transporting Wow why did these
demons need guns obviously they see he's
great with the click of death Bumi is he
because he has a gun yes he's killing
them where they come oh we got a yellow
four key we have we have a lot more a
lot more gameplay from how learners just
show you actually but so this next stuff
we wanted to actually pick up the pace
just a little bit yeah yeah full bore
and really see what this layer can do
maybe mouse and keyboard huh ooh PC
gaming okay oh my
[Music]
let's be kind of you now what what honey
Laurie kill your next Mary strike is
supercharged okay yeah now it is
oh that's a boom I've always wanted to
see the movie you just punch a guy's
head off okay all right and almost even
when it's rewarding
beat it beat it and you can't see it
it's Jason Takes Manhattan
you blood punch those things
so you got this like couch and then you
can grapple midair her head infinite
combos my chainsaw
oh yeah
the problem with games like this is then
I get kind of looking at all the scenery
- oh man who's that big fiery orb up to
the sky
this is what's gonna flash in my head
when I close my eyes tonight yeah
it's just so extremely I don't know if I
could ever beat this good how you can
make it happen I believe in you because
like the more the demons defeat you the
angrier and more determined
I've played you
the
literally he's like no one's hurting him
yeah yeah this is like a perfect or bad
day what the [ __ ] there's no no time to
taking any of these designs as as far as
video games have come I just really
appreciate when we come back to simple
pleasures
simple pleasures of annihilation I've
just destroyed so you probably noticed
there at the end that we're now giving
players the ability to take control of a
demon and invade another player's
campaign oh boy you can actually even
team up with demons to form a slayer
hunting party yeah Slayer so just a
really fun new way to add drama and
unpredictability to your campaign and
this is just one of the ways that will
allow you to enjoy doom eternal with
your friends
[Applause]
I'm always compelled to clap from people
clap okay all right we spent a bit of
time so far just giving you a taste of
how on earth but that is just one of the
many many places you'll go
yeah we do the places our storytelling
in Doom eternal we get to see how the
UAC evolved journey into new and
fantastic places in houses and fantastic
places take you to some places fantastic
demons of word fun in a doom game oh
very different environment
we're just huge so much more blue and
everything we do has a story behind it
so if you like me and you like to
investigate everything we're gonna make
it worth your time cool it's really true
we're not just making a dune game
anymore we're building a doom universe a
doom averse duper's why that shot
specific site love pathways geometric
detail and greater texture fidelity than
we have ever put on screen yeah dude
this game is great like an event yeah
like a real event and all without
sacrificing a crazy fast experience
running at 60 frames per second
yeah if that frustrated everybody loved
we actually got another one of those
cool locations we just talked about you
guys want to see a little more gameplay
no I think a lot of gameplay I'm okay so
let's take a look at what happens when
the Slayer arrives on Phobos Phobos one
guy put up his finger just admit Oh
[Music]
space is freaky kiss head ever spotted
happen I know
what did Duke that's how it is
Tyron Magnus walks down a hallway yeah
he's a lot shorter that
[Music]
giving the key given the key man
[Music]
all the thumbnails
[Music]
it's good oh here we go
oh whoa are you gonna get to use that
thing I would love that
or are you gonna have to fight against
them it's crazy to play a game where
you're not the underdog whatsoever you
just as scary as all the other scary
Wow
wow this is the greatest elevator ride
I've ever seen greatest loadings this
layer has entered the facilitate whoo yo
yeah how do you think have time to
explore yeah there's a never-ending
supply of demonic enemies because they
like explore every little thing I'm like
how do you have time to do that maybe if
you beat the entire game all the demons
it was gone and then you
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah good time to wait for you to open
you say 25 minutes is a long video but
then it's outcomes compared to the
amount of gameplay that are is he had
the many hours yeah
destinations don't look at that thing
holy show firearms over here fun about
this game is that you essentially kill
every demon the same way yeah shoot -
yeah stabs you punch in after usual
dodge lets the thing is like as
complicated as a game like doom Kings
yet it's still the same fundamental yeah
I'll look this way in decimated oh those
gonna rip his horn off he didn't even
pick up those bullets I think all those
one of those potions with potions for su
get some arm you were
[Music]
exact grindy baseline in there pass only
get six times one second
whoa Wow and what the sound effects two
different beats and stuff
[Music]
that's the coolest kill yeah
[Music]
oh I just don't know how all play is the
VR did you play this for hours though
that could be like kind of repetitive
right it might give everybody yeah I
feel like this is a good game to throw
on when you just want to like let the
let out for a minute you don't want to
get bogged down by like watching a lot
of cutsies you know strategizing
[Music]
like I'm getting a little exhausting
just watching this no it is an onslaught
100,000 to see
nice that was cool yeah yeah
whoa that's like Rambo and the portal
that's what I thought they couldn't
surprise me yeah right
you can throw a lot like heavy metal at
least for me you know like one has no
record at the time you know readers are
pretty good
we're on dude like an hour - you're
pretty good
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I'm getting exhausted
don't worry they're just depleted you'll
be ready in 15 minutes that's my
favorite move three trips them and they
fly in slow motion he tops off their
head oh that guy Oh No
[Music]
it's kind like Pumpkinhead
oh yeah look out I played her finished
in like five seconds
yeah
[Music]
if you had doing meter no man that's a
that's a lot that's a lot for my noggin
yeah to handle that was overwhelming
it's like an onslaught it's like you
know if somebody wants describe
transformers movie to me is like if you
missed it just have somebody like push
you down the stairs and throw Legos at
your face and that's kind of like what a
doom games like except if you're wearing
like headphones with some kind of metal
album playing way too loud on it I'm
always hearing people complain about
Halo franchise these days and I'm always
hearing people complain about Call of
Duty it's nice to have a game that's a
first-person shooter that's all about
[ __ ] [ __ ] up that people are
genuinely really excited for and I can
see why especially if you're already a
built-in doom fan you know they're
saying stuff about exploring and getting
to know the story behind all these
things and it's a gameplay trailer but
I'm pretty familiar with doom but are
you really gonna find a time to just do
all these cool explorations you guys are
talking about historian there's so much
shoot-'em-up going on like the whole
time yeah yeah exactly an RPG or
something where you're kind of like
talking to people and figuring out
puzzles you know you're mostly just
decimating things that I guess I
appreciate doom for being able to exist
on a meat and potatoes sort of level
we're like yeah the graphics and the
world's changed but really it's just the
fundamentals of a shooting game like a
first time shooter and I yeah it's like
I feel like they're in a nice position
having the history on their side because
people do freak out about the newest
Call of Duty and what they're changing
and what they're going after with this
one and I feel like Doom has its own
lane and as long as I keep making that
lane fun and invigorating you know they
don't really have to change that much
they're like ac/dc it's like it's the
same couple style but you know with
enough energy and enough different ways
to play I mean you got a whole set list
what's cool about this game that I think
is unique from a religious perspective
yes because I think that's the angle
that most people take when they play
Doom this is an allegory yes what
happens if you leave life is if you're a
devil worshiper this is your a game
totally and if you're a Christian or
dungeons this is your a game yeah
definitely because you get a go to hell
and
destroyed didi the Lord's work so it
doesn't matter which side of the coin
you fall on in your Christian life devil
worshiper Christ fall over yeah you're
doing the right thing when you're
playing do your are you're either a
brain'll Angela thing or or your doom
Slayer
yeah either way there's so many
different kinds of guns different guys
oh yeah there's so many kinds of guns
that plasma rifle looks pretty bomb
who's the demon at the end is that is
that a special demon that I I'm not
familiar with it it's a special boss
it's it seemed like something that was a
callback to something I don't know put
it in the comments if you made it this
far in the video listen to the creator's
talk about it like they really know what
their audiences want
yeah and they seem to be giving them
100% what they're looking for there's
even that like funny line in there about
mortal each and iam demon being an
offensive term yeah a demon being a
mortally challenges like the property no
woken those two dudes of all the people
who have to present a videogame at a
convention I bet those guys probably
have a pretty fun job of it because I
don't feel like they have a whole lot to
like fix from any previous installment
or any kind of just a bunch of insane
upgrades really yeah yeah like I feel
like they just get to come have fun yeah
I like the look at the different worlds
and stuff though I mean that's always
for me that's always the fun part of
each iteration of a doom game is just
seeing all the new ways to do what we've
always done with - I feel like you got a
point that when you were saying about
when you play you want to take in the
designs and stuff and I'm like there's
all these different creatures and
everything and you know when they were
teasing beforehand what these creatures
are like the art designs I'm like I want
time to take it in when I'm playing but
I'm not yeah halftime is that they have
to kill them right away yeah it does
look like there's kind of always an
onslaught at your at your you know
foreground or whatever it's so I'm
wondering if you know the actual
gameplay of it there will be times here
and there where you're kind of wandering
and wondering when the next ambush is
gonna start those are always fortunate
opportunities to take a look at all the
beautiful like they are really gorgeous
design
for as we have sinned and twisted as
they all are like it is others engineer
thing a beauty there I love this this
was fantastic stuff next week it's got
to get that doom Wolfenstein cross over
and over be perfect alright guys well
are you excited for the mortally
challenged game leave your comments down
below you can subscribe to the reject
nations you're an admirable recorder now
that's just something outside you can
see quick that notification bell check
us out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly cooing it's a music
video coverage love to have you become a
patron objective Hey